now to the latest provocation from North
Korea the country's leadership says it
tested a new kind of intercontinental
ballistic missile one using solid fuel
instead of liquid which could make it
quicker to launch overnight the U.S and
South Korea apparently in a counter move
conducted joint air drills over the
Korean Peninsula including F-16 Fighters
and a B-52 bomber impressive pictures
there Romeo you know raymi inocencio
looks at what it all means I want to
know as well Remy good morning hey Tony
yeah good morning solid fuel missiles
have really been a key goal of North
Korea for a very long time and North
Korean State media did broadcast the
launch of that new missile set to
Propaganda music from an undisclosed
location now these kinds of missiles can
be deployed faster easier and also more
safely a solid fuel also doesn't degrade
as fast that means they can be fueled
long before launch so that means spy
satellites might have a tougher time I'm
detecting them images also appear to
show Kim Jong-un watching the launch and
even smiling other images show him with
his daughter Kim Joo a featured
prominently and it's important to note
that anything Pyongyang does here for
the public is choreographed one North
Korea analyst says Kim may be trying to
portray an aura of stability to the
People by showing off his family and
that he may be aiming to produce solid
fuel missiles that can eventually fly 6
000 miles in Dana that is just shy of
New York in Washington D.C
thank you